hey guys just got done shooting an NC
here and I figure a while I got the
camera might as well do one of the V
logs so this is the boiling rock this is
part one and two it decided just do them
side by side because I mean they really
connect well and this is the episode
where Zuko and Sokka they go to this
prison to see if his father and Sookie
are there and sure enough they are and
they planned this great big escape my
initial reaction watching it is why was
this two episodes I was constantly
saying to myself I think I've done this
in one I even had a good escape going at
the end of the first bar and then they
back out and whatever they see the
father and Sookie there announce they
get what they could just haven't come in
earlier that they didn't need to make
this to but then I saw the climax and I
said oh no I get it that now it clicks
because man was at a good good climax
you know this show has had so many good
action scenes and so many climaxes to
their episodes this was just another
great one uh and man shocked me seeing
the the two girls turned against Azula
like that was may entirely I think or
the names and yeah just did not see a
coming but it felt like yeah this what
happened it felt like this was the
natural thing that would happen and the
reason for that because I was asking
myself why did that feel more natural
than when Zuko changed sides or rather
change back to the dark side uh and I
think the reason for it is that the
character they've created with Mae
obviously they build up that she's
naturally very bored she's bored by
everything and when Azula comes along
she's excited because she can finally do
something it's almost like she was never
given that rebellious part of her
childhood that she wanted cuz she always
got what she wanted
so she and people especially young
people you know they need they crave
something different they want to try and
take risks and do something that you
know might get them in trouble or it's
just testing the boundaries so when you
have no bow
to test it can be very boring so now we
have we have this romance that was going
on between her and Zuko she confronts
him in the prison I mean he's pretty
much at her mercy and he doesn't turn I
mean he explains himself and why he did
it
and I forgive he apologizes for just
leaving and not explaining it apart from
a note whether or not he saw it as the
right thing I think even he doesn't know
and you have that look when he's going
to escape and he locks her in the room
and they exchange this look they just
look into each other's eyes and it's
this very it's a wonderful look but it's
hard to sum up exactly what it is it's a
look of sort of an apology but also no
it's not even an apology maybe that's
what it is it's that I've chosen my side
I have feelings for you but I've chosen
my side and he runs off and and she sees
that and that's the point where she
decides to turn and that's that is so
fascinating and maybe because we haven't
gone as much into her character there is
a little bit more of a mystery to her
but you know that she is born you know
she is sort of rambunctious and wants to
do you know almost wants to get in
trouble and here is something that she
actually has placed value in you know in
this boy in this prince and she I guess
at that moment she felt it was worth
fighting for and going to prison and
riding away or whatever we I'm sure is
not going to happen but um and it's just
a great surprising moment that it feels
it feels justified it really feels like
it worked its way up to it but then the
one that really got me was a Thai Lee
changing and turning around again feels
totally justified both really shocked me
and I love it again just when a show can
surprise me like that but you feel like
yes that that was warranted which again
just emphasized Zuko um Zuko turning to
the the Fire Nation again was not it's
it's not that wasn't just
fire couldn't see it happening it's more
that they didn't show the progression
into that because they showed such a
long progression of the stroke oh he was
going through before and this turn again
I understand it because some people were
saying like you know but it's like an
alcoholic you know that they can just
turn they can turn on a whim and they
can be back in the dark place and
everything and they show the
consequences for it and that's all great
but they showed so much I mean they
showed his friggin dreams of what he was
going through when he was changing back
and he seemed legitimately happy to be
at that spot so you know to me I could
use just a little bit more and it seemed
more like they're going for the shock of
it uh and I think for care do you
develop so much the shock isn't as
powerful or at least not for me because
I know a lot of people were like oh we
and for me I could kind of see it coming
mostly because of that reason that they
didn't dive into what he was thinking
and everything because I'm like okay
they're gonna go for the surprise and
they did um but it but it's it's don't
lie it's it's an epic uh uh tightly
changing there uh was really great and
you could see it because this is
obviously a good-hearted character just
happens to kind of be on the wrong side
um and we're seeing that with a lot of
people in the Fire Nation which I like
again makes them much more human uh I
like I like Azula really being betrayed
and I like her being so angry and so
hurt by it and you know obviously she's
just gonna try and go off and and forget
about by me she says I want them to rot
I want them in the deepest darkest jail
cell and I want them to rot for the rest
of their days I mean she is obviously so
hurt by this and I like seeing a scene
like that because like I said I
mentioned before we seem to really like
villains we like villains a lot and we
like it when villains go out in a
cool-ass way you know when they're
launched off the cliff door and they
burst in do you know of potable lava or
something like that some sort of cool
awesome badass way a villain can go out
but when I think there's this real truth
in the reality that people who even when
people who do a lot bad things get
victories or a lot or either a lot of
victories or one big victory or whatever
it seems like things are going their way
they still have to live with themselves
and the reason people do a lot of bad
things is because they're not satisfied
with themselves and as much as they try
to lie to themselves and they try to
convince themselves as this character
clearly does uh the more empty they'll
find themselves when the really
important days come when they find they
have to be on their own and when those
friends and those things that you try to
get and you try to keep and you try to
possess are taken away then you start to
see what was really important and a lot
of it was being nice and sacrificing and
being you know kind and all that stuff
um and I like to I don't know they're
gonna do I like to see more of a because
she looks so you know like I said this
is so angry at these two where other
care does she'd be like oh I don't care
I'm evil uh but she looks so angry so
she was obviously so betrayed by I like
to see that keep going I hope that's the
direction they're gonna go I like to see
her like cuz there's still a few
episodes I like to see her deteriorate
if they're gonna do that because she's
been so perfect like just this perfect
villain I loved his I love to see them
not give her the bad ass you know it's a
sort of a bad ass ending I like to see
her actually like fall apart um so I
hope that's where they go with it um
what else what else what else uh you
know one other thing I'll say about that
I was talking to Carl custard
uncle yo um about this while ago we're
talking about favorite characters he was
talking about characters like Azula they
said the most fascinating thing about
those people is that they never have a
finish line and I always remember that I
Vance a very very good line is that the
even when Azula has everything I mean
she's a princess she's practically next
in line for the throne
you know and now her brother is gone and
stuff like that or even when she thinks
the avatar is gone all this stuff she
still wants to keep destroying people
she still needs that power even when she
has everything she needs even more and I
think that is such a sad tragedy of
these kind of people I think even when
people I have seen people have done
rotten bad things or have lied or
achieve it or whatever and they get
these victories but you see they still
have to live with themselves and it's
not easy for them as sometimes they
never can really live with themselves
and they fall apart so it's you know
there is a lot true to that saying
Living Well is the best revenge um you
know if you're happy with yourself
who cares who you know what X Y & Z
think or anything like that I mean
that's just the best you can ask for and
people who constantly need control and
power over others are not happy with
themselves so I again I hope they go
this route I'm talking about or think of
her the badass ending name that that'd
be cool too I don't know but it's I like
to see her fall apart cuz they fills her
up so much but regardless now there's
our stuff in this episode sorry it's art
well done that but it is two episodes I
have more time I like that when Zuko is
in this prison I like that they do
address the fact that he's they address
him catching up with some things like I
love when he comes across Sookie and
Sookie's giving him this evil look it's
like what is it and it's like did we
meet before and she's like yes you've
destroyed my village a it's like oh
sorry I mean it's just great moments
like that I love I love catching
characters up like that and that it's
not just this person's with this person
and then they go it's like they remember
what happened and I like that I like
that keeping that connection going um
what else what else the location of the
place is pretty cool and I I liked the
ingenuity I'll I like that Sokka I don't
think they need to give Sokka that
episode with the the sword training
again I haven't seen the whole show I
don't know if it's gonna come back but I
don't think it was necessary I think he
was fine as an idea guy
uh I I think that was enough because
again you see him putting his ideas into
motion the whole idea about getting that
cold cell and having that go in the
water the boiling hot water and going
across I mean that's a great idea and he
has these great ideas and I don't
they're so building up Oh what sucka
good for he's not a bender he's not
anything he was he he was this this you
know good character and any did have
these great ideas um so again I don't
know if that's gonna tie in anywhere um
maybe it is maybe it's not but and in
terms of why they did it like oh he
doesn't have anything I thought he did
it wasn't just comic relief I thought he
actually did on top of having his very
honorable moments he had his very smart
moments he was the idea guy you know
sort of the mad crazy ideas so um and
just seeing him drop that that cell into
the water and trying to go across I felt
really explored that again and yeah what
else I I think that's all the really
major stuff in this one you know at
times it sort of seemed like they were
filling up time but like I say it built
up to that ending and I get the last
thing I'll say before I sign off here is
the UH I froze like the guy in charge of
the prison or whatever you know he at
first I didn't get why he was saying cut
the wire on the train or the cart that
he was on that was gonna allow them to
escape because he would die too
but then I realized I remember that oh
hey this is actually this is a guy so
obsessed with not letting anybody escape
that he would put his own life in
jeopardy I didn't get that until they
finally get to the end and I haven't
tied up they're they're just like you
know it looks like your records been
broken and they walk away and I was like
oh that's why he was actually so
consumed you know with his honor of
keeping this the unescapable prison that
he would even sacrifice his life I love
that I love that madness that that's
just so great um so yeah I think that's
about it
uh I'll get let last thing doesn't even
connect with this episode
but it's a fault on my part there there
was a part in one of them were I think
the where the invasion where Azula said
that she knew they were going to attack
on the day of the Eclipse I was like
well when was that said it clearly was
said I Ally have this in the show and I
forgot it but when they're dressed up as
the as the Warriors and the earth King
says to them yeah there's gonna be
invasion on the Eclipse oh my bad they
made it very very clear and I just
unless it's in the previously on Avatar
I'm gonna forget to so um yeah but yeah
that that was my screw-up there and what
I know what again this is just way in
the past has nothing to with this
episode I'm gonna bring up now the earth
King okay like they tell him I know I'm
rambling but I don't care they say that
he at the beginning of this season I
hear the earth King he wanted to see the
world so he got Bear and he wrote off
and stuff like that and that's it I'm
assuming you never see him again and
he's happy-go-lucky haha he's off to see
the world and the show sir treats her
like that - bye-bye earth king te haha
no no no this guy up a lot and at
the end of the last season it looks like
he was really torn up but the earth
Kingdom it has fallen you know uh you
know we are lost and he is finally seen
you know how much of it was his fault
and how much he sure kept his eyes open
and so forth he was trying to make
things better and then there's her like
oh you just forgot his barren Road ah
haha that's our goofy character I was
not cool with that I really thought that
either even thing if they wanted him off
that's fine but haven't sent them off
and say like I'm gonna go atone for my
problems or atone for my mistakes I'm
gonna try and make things better I'm
gonna go and see what I can do I'm gonna
explore this world see what I can
discover make it even out - what you did
with the character before to even out
his mistakes or at least attempt to even
out those mistakes but or even if he was
like tee hee ha ha and rode off and
everyone looked at him like wow that
guy's totally nuts or even that would
make more sense but it's the fact that
the show allows him to go off with no
responsibility for his actions that
bothered me
I know it's it's not even like one of my
favourite characters it's one my least
favorite characters honestly but it's
the fact that they let that go it's like
the Great Divide I'm just dead know that
that should have been left out so or
that should have been explained better
something better good than done with
that but that has nothing to do with
this episode I just wanted to get it in
there before I forgot so that's the to
earth king things that I should have
brought up before so I'm just making it
up here because I reviewed two episodes
in this one I figured I have the time so
guys that's about it I shall see you
later